Dr Zak many people have the
misconception that using the Sak during
the fast in Ramadan is discouraged could
you just clarify this point please there
are many people who think that using
seak while your fasting is discouraged
it is based on the Hadith the same
Hadith I quoted earlier of s bukari
volume 3 in the book of fasting Hadith
number 194 and 1894 Prophet mam said
that by Allah in whose hand is my soul
the breath of a person who fasts is
sweeter to Allah subhana wa ta'ala than
the scent of musk now based on this
people think that if you use the breath
the bad breath that normally comes in a
person who fast will not be there so
Allah will not enjoy the breath and
based on this they think it is
discouraged in fact we should realize
that when a person is using theak tooth
stick it does not stop the bad breath
which normally comes when person fasts
because when you use the tooth stick the
it normally massages the gums and if
there are any food particles in between
the teeth like how you use a toothbrush
it is somewhat similar to that the bad
breath of fasting comes from the stomach
because no food enter the stomach and
that's how it comes so no way does IT
contract that and furthermore beloved
Prophet mm Salli wasallam said it's
mentioned inkari R number two Hadith
number 887 that the Beloved Prophet said
that if it wasn't too difficult for my
umah I would have made it compulsory to
use theak before every prayer how W is
compulsory so the prophet said if it
wouldn't have been difficult for the
umah you have made it compulsory to use
the every time before prayer and that
means it is a recommended act and if it
wasn't good for fasting you would have
mentioned it like how we mentioned for
excessive sing of water Hadith of Abu da
Vol number two Hadith number 2360 where
our beloved Prophet said that sniff
water
excessively through your nose while
doing ablution except while fasting that
means sniffing water excessively is good
but don't do it while fasting because
there are danger that will go into the
throat and menter the stomach so here
too if it was a disadvantage the prophet
would have said that I would have told
my um to use the Sak except while
fasting So based on this using theah it
is a recommended act it is must
and you should do it and insh it we get
your Rewards